the titans are so realistically drawn
but not realistic at the same time yeah
this clip really stands out for having
some very fluid animation a really cool
approach to perspective the way
animation is kind of taught in japan is
more energy influenced so why would they
have decided to shift to doing fully cg
titans
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
get 15 off your next purchase
hey welcome back to another episode of
animators react we are joined by alex
today very very talented cg animator
i've worked on things like frozen 2 ryan
the last dragon hotel transylvania right
now i'm working on the recently
announced bad guys over at dreamworks
this time around with alex we're going
to be taking a deep dive into anime most
notably for me attack on titan one of my
favorite shows i'm really excited to
dive into that one how did you get into
anime probably ninja scroll i was gonna
say the same thing everybody's really
like yeah because you couldn't get them
so you'd have to go to like blockbuster
or video store and hope they had one of
the five vhs tapes so it was like ghost
in the shell cowboy beef up man i was
into toonami as a kid so like dragon
ball z gundy wing that was my jam yeah
so alex what would you say are the main
differences between anime and other
styles of animation as far as i know
that the way animation is kind of taught
in japan is more energy influenced so
it's more about the feeling than getting
the drawings right sometimes people are
just like i just won't draw it good and
it doesn't matter because you're gonna
feel it like some anime leans 100 into
that energy idea and so you're feeling
it you're seeing them fly around zip
around they're just kind of like shapes
of the trail so when you say energy
based animation the first thing that
comes to my mind is the tournament fight
from my hero academia
[Applause]
what i think hero identity does really
great is that it's grounded like as
extreme as this is it's within the rules
that they've set and you always know
what's happening
i don't know much about todoroki's
fighting style todoroki when he's like
first really shown in the challenge he
like freezes a robot it's just a one
drawing like this i think and then the
background is going
so you're just like whoa
this is awesome and it just kind of goes
like this and a big giant ice thing
climbs up the robot if you think about
it it's just the background moving it's
just a drawing of a hand doing this and
the background is moving and tracking in
a way that makes you believe the
character's not really doing anything
interesting in this whole scene but it's
just like the feeling and the flow and
being smart about their pencil mileage
pencil mileage yeah what's possible
pencil mileage is like if you were to
take all the lines that you have to draw
that robot and put them in one line it
would be miles and miles interesting
yeah i made up that definition but
that's the idea
is is how much work you have to put on
is being smart about how you're using
your time anime does that arguably
better than anyone if you draw a face
once and then you draw a mouth that's
low pencil mileage just so then you can
shift your focus and expenses and budget
to the scenes where they just go all out
when watching like an attack of titan
episode and there's a lot of standing
around and talking and a lot of shots
that like are somebody's hand yeah or
somebody listening or somebody's just
somebody's mouth or something like that
it's like oh there's gonna be a big
fight scene at the end of this yeah yeah
it's like
non-anime people see shots like they're
like why do you like this no it's just
like one drawing of a mouth going you're
like this means something good is coming
yeah they're saving their frames for
later yeah don't blame me for what
happens next
uh so this shot right here you know it
goes back to the efficiency thing he's
barely moving but his clothes are but
they're adding these short thick
vertical lines just all over around the
edge of his body and just like
flickering and it really makes the
moment seem very intense he's not moving
yeah at all and yet the whole frame has
so much energy there's like all these
wind moving around his clothes are
moving his hair is moving but he's still
yeah so what you call those is like
action lines action lines usually it's
first shot like we saw with todoroki
zipping across the ground with his hand
you'll see those action lines it just
gives energy to a shot that you might
just have like a cycle of probably only
two to four drawings where you're seeing
some texture moves we've actually done
action lines on some of our anime videos
before like anime baseball and yeah
fidget spinners it's like it's really
easy you just like you put some lines on
the edges or top and bottom yeah but
like he actually like the outline of him
his silhouette is actually turned into
action lights too i found that pretty
interesting there so in anime their
motion blur their version of smear frame
or multiples it's almost like the lines
are drifting almost off the character
the lines start peeling away so it makes
like action lines coming off that's why
the edges down the bottom are mostly
solid but all the edges on the backside
they're all like
exactly you know what's so funny it's
like motion blur is a literal like
optical artifact yeah from just how
cameras work yeah but as a side effect
they also imply motion in a really
interesting way and so that's what we've
i guess seen animators just try to
replicate yeah through various ways
so alex roughly how many drawings would
be in an episode like this hero academia
on an average i think they run around
three thousand of four thousand drawings
in an episode which is a lot which is a
feel like that's a lot it's a lot but
that's the limited look you're looking
at so when you're like anime is limited
it's cause it's only four thousand
drawings but when you're talking about
like a legend of korra the first season
has around 18 000 drawings per episode
throughout the season long time levi
still a runter have you grown some
so the kenny versus levi fight is one of
the most requested animator react clips
we have this clip really stands out for
having some very fluid animation and a
really cool approach to perspective and
notably a cg background and then
hand-drawn characters on top of it
here we go i love it here we go
it's interesting how they make a point
to have his face get close to the camera
to give you the character moment still
in the middle of all of this that's one
of the things like it's like the camera
it always goes in out in and out and it
just adds a lot of energy to what would
be just like traveling down a street
yeah this shot oh
yeah i mean those drawings in the push
perspective i love myself some push
perspective
what's push perspective just that like
how big his foot is like there's no
camera lens spoiler there's nobody
filming this
everything has to be created you're
choosing to film that moment or this
sequence with a different lens you know
if you're to film this in real life you
know they have shots where it's like the
perspective of levi's like a 30
millimeter lens and without cutting
without changing lenses or zooming out
suddenly you're getting like the
distortion of like an eight millimeter
lens or ten millimeter lens so that
field of view is staying consistent for
the background but for levi is going
at will like you're saying so it's like
this weird disconnect that you can't get
even in computer generated imagery the
problem is like in cg or in computers
it's easy to not think about stuff
because the computer is like i got you
yeah and so it's easy to be like he got
me right
and then you like show it to someone who
knows or you see it later and you're
like you told me you would handle this
maya or after effects or
whatever like you promised me and most
of the time it's like i tried my best
you know computers they're math-based
you know so you're going to get the
mathematically correct image and when it
comes to drawing things by hand that's
not at all what you're getting exactly
you're forced to think about every line
because you're drawing it so for a scene
like this because of the crazy motion
you think it's better to animate the
background and the camera first and then
decide on your character and what they
do or flip that around this is like a 50
50 for me of like what would be better
get the background set up and then just
like live within it
and that might be more efficient time
wise but also giving the animator
freedom to just be like this is gonna be
awesome and i can visualize it and you
just have to like track this and i'll
give you a few markers or whatever can
also kind of open up the gates
all right so we're always asking about
animations here ren's been talking about
anime i'm gonna throw an anime prompt
here i want to know about
ground-breaking animes i know for
example like the original gundam was
groundbreaking with how it drew
perspective shifts on the robots and its
approach drawing missiles for example
but i don't know much more beyond that
so maybe you guys can help me out and
leave a comment about some
groundbreaking animes and include why
why you love it so much that's gonna be
so helpful for us in terms of finding
more clips to show alex and other
animators that come in
okay so now i want to take a look at the
titans and how they've changed over the
course of the show
the titans are so realistically drawn
but not realistic at the same time yeah
it's like so uneasy feeling which is
exactly what you want but yeah it's
super intentional yeah i like how the
titans are drawn very much in reference
to like european paintings like medieval
tapestries it gives them a really unique
feeling yeah it's so unique but it's
like slightly exaggerated like their
eyes are bigger their smiles are uncanny
it very much so emotes a weird weird
emotion you're just like oh yeah because
i feel like that's even more effective
than if they actually intentionally made
them look scary yeah they're supposed to
be scary creatures they're big giant
monsters that are going to eat you but
they went about achieving that scary
factor without actually making them look
scary the show also kind of fudges its
own sense of scale a lot of the time
he's huge he looks like a freaking
skyscraper especially when he's like
walking through in his fist is the size
of houses aaron is also very huge here
you have people literally standing on
his shoulder and like they could
probably like burrow into his ear yeah
the sense of scale that this episode
makes us feel is off from what the
reality would be
so the colossal titan is a 60 meter
titan that's like a little over 200 feet
tall aaron yeager's titan is a 15 meter
class titan which is about 50 feet but
then they exaggerate the scale so much
he runs up and is now about to try to
stop the colossal titan from moving
technically aaron's titan is exactly 25
as tall as the colossal titan he should
come up to his knees he's so tiny yeah
he's tiny he's at the ankle there but
then the next shot he's almost up to the
knee so the reason i think they did that
is to help emphasize the actual
character moment yeah it's aaron going
up against this huge unstoppable force
and to accentuate that from like a story
perspective they exaggerated the scale
yeah you know like in that shot he is as
tall as the first story of the building
that's like what 10 feet yeah he's like
now at a like 20 scale of what he
actually should be and they're taking
liberties with the scale of all this
because it helps force the story and the
emotions you feel like oh man he's
actually pushing back on the titan's
foot and then the titan's like this end
yeah
it's like kind of all over the place and
i'd like to think it's for feeling it
could be for time and budget but a
consistency to things that are trackable
i think is important because you're
trying to sell people that this is a
real world and real characters and they
have limits and that's the thing is that
the visual context says one thing but
the numbers that they're constantly
reminding viewers says a different thing
it's just i find it interesting and
that's why i'm making a whole video
about all of this i actually have cg
renderings of these titans composited
into real life footage to give you a
better sense of scale of how big these
titans actually would really be in real
life subscribe to the corridor crew
channel that video comes out tomorrow
i've been working hard on it i hope you
like it
in the first three seasons with the
exception of the colossal titan everyone
was hand animated but in the fourth
season they switched studios and they
made a decision that all of the titans
would be computer generated they'd be 3d
models with a toon shading rendering to
it in my opinion i think it works pretty
well yeah i think they did a great job
but aaron's titan has a definite
different look to him now especially his
face i mean that looks pretty good to me
so why would they have decided to shift
to doing fully cg titans in season four
when they didn't really do it for most
of the previous seasons i would imagine
it's more budgetary in time and just
availability of talent uh the studio
handling the season is studio mapa
they're also doing shows like god of
high school and jiu jitsu kaisan which
are two of my favorites it's worth
mentioning like in the first season of
attack on titan you basically get one
titan which is aaron's titan and then
once in a while other titans show up
yeah in season four there's like four
different titans on screen in like every
episode at the same time yeah yeah and
so you know you run into the issue that
you know it's almost like the same issue
it's like mechanical drawings like
drawing gundams you have these crazy
complicated figures with a whole bunch
of detail
that that detail needs to track with
them as they move so you know how do you
solve that how do you solve that problem
because as you're talking about you have
a budget with how many frames you can
draw you know so if you do the whole
character in cg you can change poses and
do everything you want and it's not
costing you any drawing yeah this wasn't
like day two of season one where they're
like should we just do this in cg guys
i think it's like they did it then
they're like how do we make this crazy
leave eye shot what if we did the
background in cg that worked out no one
really cared we did the colossal titan
which has a crazy amount of detail and
stuff in cg everyone was like that's
really cool yeah and so now we have
these designs we have this animation
language we have all the stuff we need
to inform the final product we're going
to be able to get a tighter thing
[Music]
so this is a cg model here yeah that one
feels more cg you can see the cg more it
used to be more in the shaving
and now it's more in the movement i
would argue they're trying their best
and they're doing a good job i think
aaron overall is pretty great but as
soon as you enter the cg realm you think
now what can i do instead of using it as
a tool to get what you were able to get
before more efficiently and so it's
gonna feel different which immediately
when your four seasons in is gonna be
like something feels off
that's gonna stand out it's not the
style of the show the style of the show
is based on its limits and so from an
animation perspective
they're trying to get a little bit more
out of it it feels like and i think with
this they probably bit off more than
they could chew i think they chose it
for probably the right reasons but then
they just don't have the experience yet
i would say somewhere like studio mir
who worked on voltron i think voltron
voltron's one of the most successful
tv series with 2d anime style animation
and cg animated stuff that doesn't feel
jarring and they are pushing like the
frame count and stuff with their cgs but
it's just integrated in a really unique
way because of how they're layering
their effects so do you think the cg
titans worked out it's hard to say if it
was successful or not in the sense of
matching what was there previously i'd
say no not a hundred percent but the
result i think is successful in the
sense of you're getting the story you're
seeing cool action it feels like it's
coming from the same world i would say
out of all the aspects that aren't
working there needed to be probably a 2d
pass over the cg for textures and line
work just for the little details and
scratches they like to do and then the
animation needed to be limited further i
don't think it's far off it's like 85
percent there and people are reacting
very strongly like too strongly yes 100
too strongly this the amount of work and
complexities in this season alone are
insane and then to do what they did with
the titans is a mountain of work that
they accomplished and told the story
and did everything they needed to do the
technology is like almost there have
they drastically improved within the
series whether it's a different studio
or not i would argue yes so whether it's
successful or not are they making
progress in integrating cg into anime in
a smart way and a good use of it
absolutely
so you're sitting on the bus you got
some time to kill but you don't want
everybody on the bus
to know that you're watching anime well
what do you do
you put in some wireless earbuds that's
right these are the raycon everyday e25s
if you are in the market for something
that has seamless bluetooth pairing
raycon offers high quality sound at a
price that's half that of the starting
competition the earbuds themselves come
with six hours of battery life and they
have a self-charging case there are no
wires or stems or things sticking out of
your ear good seal so you don't get a
lot of background noise and they don't
fall out very easy
you want to watch your anime you want to
blast it these offer more bass you got a
whole bunch of colors you got a whole
bunch of fits and you know what if
something doesn't work out they offer a
45 45-day free return policy and on top
of that if you click the link in our
description below or you go to buy recon
calm quarter crew you get 15 off these
raycon earbuds are nice and they have
been a long time sponsor of the channel
which we really appreciate anyways
thanks waikon and uh you know the next
time you just want to blast that strange
rock and roll anime intro for the show
that you're really into well these are
the the ones you'll turn to to make it
happen jam it out to the beginning of
neon genesis i mean come on that opening
song for neon genesis it's the most
banging theme song for any anime i mean
the attack on titan one very close
very close but nothing beats cruel
angel's thesis
anyways back to the episode
alex you dropped so much knowledge on us
about this crazy world of animation and
like animation's one of those things
that it nearly draws you in when you sit
down there's like there's some it's like
music it's like you don't need to
understand why it just does for shedding
some light in this process thank you so
much i really appreciate you coming in
thank you for all of you out there who
would like to see more of alex's work
you can follow him personally at
snowmation or check out some of his
bigger projects at double plus
productions oh and real quick don't
forget subscribe because tomorrow attack
on titan is being put in real life what
would it look like well you're probably
looking at it right now but stay tuned
tomorrow we'll see you next time
especially if you've subscribed
[Laughter]